So, uh the last topic of the course that
we'll discuss today is going to be
something called common knowledge.
So, throughout the course we've often
said things like, "Oh,
we've assumed that the game is common
knowledge." But, we've never really been
very precise about exactly what that
means when we say the game itself is
common knowledge. So, today we're going
to introduce formally this concept of
common knowledge. And uh this is a topic
that has quite a long history and has
been studied across many fields. So,
philosophers thought about this issue,
logicians and mathematicians thought
about it, and then economists have
thought about it as well. So, uh
the starting point of our model
of common knowledge is we're going to
say there's some set, this is called
omega,
of states of the world.
And there's various interpretations
about what these states of the world
are. You could imagine uh every state
specifying every possible detail about
the world, every arrangement of atoms.
Of course, that's not a very useful
model. So, often when we talk about
states of the world, we talk about the
states of the world, the dimensions or
aspects of the world that are relevant
to the problem at hand. And I think this
is all a bit abstract. So, as I
introduce the model, I want to on the
other side introduce some leading
examples to kind of make this concrete.
So, as a leading example, let's imagine
we're uh learning about the roll of a
die, and therefore the state of the
world is just going to be
these possible values.
Of course, this is a huge
simplification, uh but I think this is
going to be a good way to uh to fix
ideas.
So, a die is rolled. It can take any
value between one and six.
And it's also helpful to represent these
states kind of geometrically here.
So, the exact arrangement doesn't
matter, it just makes it easier to draw
the pictures. So, I'm going to think of
the states as being like this, 1 2
3 4
5 6.
And then once we have the set of states
of the world, we can then talk about
each player's, it's called their
information partition. So, we're going
to say an agent,
say agent I,
has
information partition
KI.
So, the subscript I indicates this is
something this represents the
information for player I, and the K
comes from the word knowledge, which
we'll talk about later on. We'll talk
about what knowledge is.
Now, partition is just a mathy word that
says we're arranging these different
states, these different dots, and we're
splitting them up into groups. That's
what a partition is. It just puts things
into groups. So, in this opening
example, let's imagine the groups are
like this.
So, this is an example of one possible
information partition for player I.
We've partitioned the six states into
four different groups, and each of these
groups, they're sometimes called a cell.
So, we might say that this partition uh
assigns the states into one of four
cells. The first cell contains states
one and two. This cell contains only
state three. This cell contains only
state five. And these cells contain uh
states four and six.
And
the word partition may remind you when
we talked about extensive form games, we
talked about a player's information
partition, and this is the same uh the
same concept here. So, what's the
interpretation of this?
The interpretation is that a player,
player I, does not learn the actual
state. They don't actually see the roll
of the die, but what they do learn is
which cell the state lies in.
So, in this case the player might learn
the state of the world is in this cell.
And if they learn that, then they can
say, "Well, I know the die was either
one or two, but I can't distinguish
between one or two."
And similarly, but in this state, when
the player learns that the state is in
this cell of the partition, they know
for certain that the state was three.
Now, it's convenient to then introduce
or denote
KI of omega
to be the cell of the partition that
contains state omega. This is just a
definition that's going to make it a bit
easier to reason about these things.
So, this is going to be informally
the cell of the partition
containing omega.
So, again, I think it's easier to just
see it in example. Let's look at our
example over here.
What would KI
of
say four
be?
Well, KI of four is going to be the cell
of the partition that contains the state
four.
In this case, that's going to be this
cell,
and we need to name this cell. Well,
this is the cell that contains states
four and six. So, this we're going to
write here, this equals 4 6.
So, the what we're saying here is
the
when the state is four, the cell that
contains four is the cell 4,6. And then
as just one more example to make sure
we're clear, we could say KI of three,
well, the cell containing three is just
this cell that only contains three. So,
this is going to be
just three.
Any questions about just this notation
so far?
All right. So, now
we can start talking about
knowledge.
So, what does it mean to know something?
Well, the player doesn't necessarily
know exactly what the state is.
But, they may be able to say that the
state satisfies certain properties, or
the state lies in some smaller set, and
that's exactly what we're going to how
we're going to define knowledge. I guess
that maybe the most difficult thing when
we first think about knowledge is, what
do you form knowledge about? When I say
I know something, what does that that
mean?
And the key point is knowledge is going
to be formed about what we call an
event.
And we can just think of this
intuitively. I might say, "I know
that the die is odd."
And if I say that, I'm making a
statement about the event that the state
is either 1 3 or 5, the possible odd
realizations. So, first we're going to
define an event, and this notation may
be familiar to you if you've taken a
class on probability theory. An event E
is just a subset of the state space
omega.
So, as an example,
e.g.,
the event E equals 1 3 5,
formally, it's a subset of the state
space, but colloquially we might say
this is the event that the die is odd.
that the state
of the die
is odd.
So, now that we have the first piece, we
can talk about does a player know E? Do
they know that the die is odd? But, we
need one more piece of notation here
because, well, whether I know the die is
odd is going to depend on what the
actual value of the die is.
If the die is six, I'm not going to know
that the die is odd.
So, our definition is going to describe
knowledge in a particular state.
So,
we're going to say in state omega,
player I
knows E.
So, notice here that our definition
depends on two or maybe three things. It
depends on what the actual state is,
that certainly affects knowledge. It
depends on which player we're talking
about because some players know things
that other players don't. And it depends
on the fact or the statement or the
proposition that we're actually knowing,
this event E.
So, we say in state omega, player knows
E if
Well,
we're going to just write it in math and
then interpret it. KI of omega is a
subset
of
Let's interpret this.
If the state is omega,
well, the player is informed by their
information partition, not necessarily
that the state is actually omega, but
they're informed of which cell of the
partition the state lies in.
So, all the player learns, all the
player, quote unquote, knows is that the
state lies in this cell of their
partition.
And if that cell is a subset of E, then
the player can conclude that the event
must be E. They don't know exactly which
uh state has been realized, but they
know whichever state has been realized,
it must be in here, and therefore it
must be in here. And this is exactly uh
how we're going to define knowledge. So,
I think let's uh it's kind of easier to
to go through an example again.
So, let's here think of an event, the
event that the die is at most four.
Okay? So, that's going to be
this event here.
And we can ask, well, does this player,
the player I whose uh information
partition is represented here, do they
know event E? Or another way of we might
say it is do they know that event E has
occurred?
Well, it's certainly going to depend on
what the die actually was. So, let's
ask. If the die is five, does the player
know E? Do they know that the event E
has occurred?
No. Because this cell is not a subset of
five. And in fact, there's only going to
be three states, this one, this one, and
this one where the player knows the
event E. So, let's write that down over
here as an example.
So, I guess here I've changed my event
E. Let's call it the event
E prime.
So, let's consider the event E prime,
which is 1 2 3 4.
So, this is the event that the die is at
most four.
And let's just go through each of our
cases. So, if the state is either one or
two,
let's start if the state is one.
If the state is one, well, the player
knows that the state lies in the cell 1
2.
And because the set 1 2 is a subset of
the set E prime, we conclude by our
definition that in state one, the player
knows the event is E.
So, we have
K I
of one is a subset of E prime, which
means
player I
knows E prime
in the state one.
And we could reason analogously about
state two,
and we could reason analogously about
state three. Now, let's worry about
state four. I think that's maybe a
tricky case.
So, state In state four,
the cell of the partition for player I
is the cell 4 6.
So, in this case,
K I of four
is not a subset
of E prime.
Oops.
Why? Well, this cell 4 6 is not entirely
contained within the yellow box. It
breaks the yellow box, and parts of this
cell lie outside the yellow box.
So, we conclude that in state four,
player I
does not know
E prime.
Now,
notice the difference here.
When the state is one, the event E prime
has uh has occurred,
and the player knows that it has
occurred.
In the state four,
event E prime has occurred because four
is in E prime, yet the player does not
know this. And then we can have an even
easier case. Let's look at K I of five.
And again, K I of five
is not a subset of E prime.
So, here player I
does not know
E prime.
But notice this kind of an interesting
difference here. In state four, E prime
has occurred, but the player I doesn't
know it.
In state five, E prime has not occurred,
and the player doesn't know it.
Uh
And this is consistent with the way that
we drew information partitions and
thought about extensive form games uh
previously.
So, I guess the first thing we might
ask, well,
we we saw kind of three possibilities
here.
E prime occurs, and we know it.
E prime occurs, and we don't know it.
And E prime doesn't occur, and we don't
know it. You might ask, is it ever
possible that I know as an event when
the event doesn't happen?
And it turns out that's going to be
impossible, and we're going to uh make
that precise next.
So,
I guess the next definition we need,
well, we've said what it means for
player I to know an event in a given
state.
But now we can talk about, well, in
which states does a player know a given
event E? And that itself is another
event. So, now the event
that player I
knows E
is given by
Well, we're going to call it K I of E.
So, this is going to be the set of all
states in which player I knows that
event E has occurred.
So, let's write this down
mathematically.
It's the state
omega.
First, maybe we'll write in words
that at omega,
player I
knows E.
So, this is itself an event because it's
a collection of states, and it's the
collection of all states such that in
that state, player I knows that event E
has occurred.
And now we can just plug in
our definition from here to make this
more precise.
And we can say
This is the set of omega omega such that
So, all I've done is I've replaced this
informal statement that player I knows E
to a more precise statement of what that
knowledge means according to this
definition uh over here.
And now we can try to formalize this
property that a player can only know
something if it's true.
That if in some state I know an event E
holds, then it must be the case that the
event E actually holds. And let's state
that mathematically and then prove it.
So, here's our maybe first
very basic result.
K I of E
is a subset
of E.
So, let's understand what this means.
This says in any state of the world in
which player I knows that E has
occurred,
it must be the case that that state is
actually in E, and therefore the event E
has in fact occurred.
And the proof of this is actually
I mean, I think conceptually maybe hard,
but mathematically
uh pretty straightforward.
Let's We want to argue that this set
is a subset of this set. So, we're going
to take an arbitrary thing in this set,
and argue that it must be in this set.
Okay? So, let's choose
some state omega
that's in
K I of E.
Right?
And now let's just apply our definition.
So, what does it mean that state omega
is in K I of E?
If we apply our definition, what can we
conclude about omega?
We just want to go to our definition.
Yeah, Amy?
Right. So, this is just by definition,
right? If we choose omega in here, well,
by definition that means K I of omega
is a subset of E. We just We haven't
done much here. We've just used our
definition.
And then I would argue we're basically
done. What's the last thing we need to
see? We We want to argue that in fact
omega is in E.
So, what do we need to do?
Yeah?
Yeah, so we're basically done. K I omega
is the cell of the partition that
contains omega. So, in particular, omega
is in here. So, what that tells us
is that omega
is in K I of omega, which is a subset of
E.
And therefore,
omega is in E.
Maybe that's just a mathier way we can
look at it over here.
If I'm in some state,
and the cell containing that state is
entirely contained in this yellow box,
then the state must be in the yellow
box. That's all we're saying.
Uh and this is kind of a
a fundamental property of knowledge. I
should maybe point out an alternative
approach to modeling knowledge is not to
work with a primitive partition, but to
start with this function that tells us
uh which events do we know, and then
imposing axioms or properties on this
function. And if you impose enough
properties on this function, you can
show that it must be derived from some
partition in this way. But we're we're
not going to go through this uh this
entire exercise.
Okay. So, now we've just talked about
things that a single player knows. Now,
we're going to talk about multiple
players at the same time.
So, let's uh
come back over here.
Do a really
simple example.
So, now let's consider we have two
players.
We have players one and two.
And each player may know different
things about the state, and therefore
each player is going to have their own
information partition. So, player one is
going to have their information
partition K1
and player two is going to have their
information partition
K2.
And let's represent the state as we did
before.
So, this is state 1 2
3 4
5 6. And I think it's easier now if we
use colors, so let's put
uh player
one's information partition in blue.
And let's say that uh
player one's
information partition looks like this.
And now let's say that player two's
information partition
uh looks like this.
So, intuitively, what does player one
learn? Player one learns either that the
die is one or two or that the die is
three or four or that the die is five or
six.
What does player two learn? They learn
either that the die is odd or that the
die is even.
So, now we can talk about the different
information that the players have.
Uh and now let's draw
an
event here.
So, let's let E
be the event 1 2 3 4 5.
So, now maybe first let's ask what is
the Let's describe the event
K1 of E.
So, this is going to be in which states
does player one know that event E has
occurred?
Any ideas here?
What is this going to be? Yeah, give me.
Oh, 1 2 3 4.
Uh yeah, and actually we can just write
them all together. Yeah, so 1 2 3 4,
right? In any of these states, they're
So, that's an important point. The The
object here, it's not a collection of
cells, it's a collection of states,
right? So, it is the states in this cell
and the states in this cell. So, all
together we get 1 2 3 4.
Okay?
And then we can ask what about player
two?
Well, similarly, player two, it's only
going to be 1 3 and 5
because these are the only states that
are in a cell that's contained in the
yellow box. So, we get
1 3 5.
But now we can ask another question
which is what is K1 of E
intersect K2 of E?
So, let's try to interpret this set.
This is the set of states where
player one knows E and player two knows
E.
And if we just read it off here, we can
see these are the states one and three.
So, we can say
in state three
player one knows E has occurred and
player two knows E has occurred.
But now we can start asking about maybe
a a more confusing question.
Does player one know
that both players know that event E has
occurred?
Let's try to think through what that
would mean, okay?
So, we want to ask
we want to look at the set K1
of K1 of E
intersect K2 of E.
So, this means I'm player one
in which states do I know that I know
event E and my opponent player two knows
event E. So, now we can start thinking
about interactive knowledge. What do I
know about what other players know?
And you know, it's kind of a mouthful to
say it, but mathematically it's not too
hard, right?
We've just said what this is. This is 1
3.
So, what is K1 of 1 3?
Yeah?
It's just the empty set because there
are no states in which player one's cell
of his partition is a subset of 1 3.
So, this is one possibility.
It can be the case
So, we can say informally, what does
this mean? It means there are states in
the world where both players one and two
know that the event is E,
but there is no state of the world where
player one knows that both players know
that the event is E.
Okay?
And in fact, this motivates uh one more
definition.
Let's define
and this is what we might call mutual
knowledge.
So, it gets a bit messy to keep talking
about do I know that player one knows
something and player two knows something
and player three knows something. So,
let's just introduce notation for the
event that everyone knows that some
event has occurred.
So, we'll say
in state omega
event E
is mutual knowledge
if
well
K I omega
is a subset of E
for all I, for all players I that we're
talking about.
Maybe we'll say I equals 1 through N cuz
we often work with N players.
And then once we have this definition
we can just naturally define
Well, here I've said in a given state an
event is mutual knowledge if everyone
knows it.
But now we can ask about the event that
everyone knows something or the event
that this event is mutual knowledge. I
know it's getting to be a a bit of a
mouthful, but we can give another
definition
and we'll just say
K of E
is equal to the intersection or maybe
I'll write it this way.
K1 of E
intersect K of E.
So, this is precisely
the
set of states
where player one knows event E, player
two knows event E, and everyone else
knows event E.
Okay?
So, if we want to rewrite this equation
star over here
using our new notation
we could write that is the event K1
of K of E.
So, our new notation
E is an event.
K of E is the event that E is mutual
knowledge. It's the event that everyone
knows E is true.
And K1 of K of E is the event that
player one knows that everyone knows
that the event E is true.
So, what this highlights is that mutual
knowledge sounds pretty strong,
but
it's actually not quite as strong as you
might think because it may be that we
all know something, but there's a player
who doesn't know that we all know
something.
And that suggests that we might need to
go a step deeper.
So, we could then look at
what is the interpretation K squared of
E
is equal to K
of K of E. So, in words, what would uh
What would you describe this as? This is
the event that that what?
K of K
of E. Yeah? Everyone knows that everyone
else knows that E is true, right? So, we
might call
We called this mutual knowledge. It's
kind of first order mutual knowledge.
This we might call second order mutual
knowledge. Everyone knows something and
on top of that, everyone knows that
everyone knows it.
So, this is
maybe
second order
mutual knowledge.
But that's still too weak because it
could be that everyone knows something
and everyone knows that everyone knows
something, but maybe people don't know
that everyone knows that everyone knows
it. So, we have to go a step deeper.
And we finally get to maybe what I'll
okay say common knowledge
CK of E.
Now we can formally define this thing
that we've been informally talking about
throughout the course.
CK of E is
K of E
intersect K squared of E
intersect K cubed of E
and it goes on forever.
So, now we have a formal definition of
common knowledge.
Event E is common knowledge or in other
words, the set of states in which event
E is common knowledge are precisely the
states in which everyone knows E
everyone knows that everyone knows E
everyone knows that everyone knows that
everyone knows E and this goes on no
matter how long this the length of this
chain is. And this is a very very
demanding property uh that we've
implicitly been kind of relying on
throughout the course. Now, I think you
might think, well, why are we going
through all this? This is kind of
we're just playing math games, you know,
what does this really have any content?
So, I know for the next part of the
course of the class want to go over kind
of a famous riddle that illustrates how
different common knowledge of something
can be from just mutual knowledge or
from first or second order mutual
knowledge. So, this is kind of a classic
riddle that will we'll go over.
Um
so this is sometimes called
I don't know, it has many names. The
sage and the children, I don't know. Or
the teacher, there's so many stories we
could use. Let's let's use the teacher
and the students.
And here's the the story of course it's
kind of a a bit of a a silly puzzle, but
I think it illustrates the ideas really
well. So, we have three students
call them one, two, and three.
And
yeah, there's various versions of it.
We'll use the version of hats. So, each
student is wearing a hat.
Each student's hat is white or red.
Why do we use hats? Well, the point is
when you're wearing a hat, you can see
other people's hats, but not your own.
So, you can observe the color of
everyone else's hat, but you can't
observe the color of your own hat.
And
so, we'll say that each student
observes
the others hats
but not her own.
Okay.
So,
let's suppose that all the hats are
actually red.
I should put it in red.
Um so, all hats are red. This is sort of
an assumption.
Uh it's really a statement about what
the true state omega is. So, the true
state is that all the hats are red.
Uh and then the teacher is going to ask
all the students, do you know what color
your hat is?
Now, for this riddle to kind of work
out, it must be the case that we're
assuming everyone is truthful. No one's
lying to the teacher. Um so, the teacher
asked, do you know your hat color?
And
we should be a little precise when it
means know your hat color means either
you know your color your hat is red or
you know your hat is white. It's what it
means to know your hat color.
Um
what would the students answer be if
they're truthful?
They look around, do they do they know
their hat color?
No, right? They can see other people's
hats, but they can't see their own. They
know others hat colors, they don't know
their own. So, do you know your own hat
color? The answer is no.
Okay.
Then the teacher makes an announcement.
The teacher says, so she the teacher
announces
at least one hat is red.
Have people seen heard of this riddle
before? I'm curious. Anyone? One person?
Two? Okay, so not too many. Okay. So,
the teacher says, at least one hat is
red.
And now she's going to go through and
ask these questions again to the
students one by one. So, she's going to
go to student one, S1
and say, do you know your hat color?
And still, I mean, knowing that at least
one hat is red doesn't give any that
student any information about their own
hat. So, that student is going to say
no.
And then the teacher goes to student two
and says, do you know your hat color?
And the student says no.
And crucially, when the teacher is
asking these students, the other
students get to observe the answers. So,
these are public questioning and we're
assuming everyone's truthful.
And then she goes to student three
and that student says yes. Now, I know
my hat color.
Now, I think people this I think was
first developed in the 1950s, these
mathematicians were really shocked by
it. So, why why is this kind of
shocking? I hope people are shocked. Um
it's shocking well
it doesn't feel like the teacher's
announcement should have made any
difference. The teacher announced
something that everyone knew.
The teacher said, at least one hat is
red. Well, if everyone's hat is red, any
student can look around and in fact see
that there's at least two red hats.
So, why would the announcement that at
least one hat is red
change the dynamics that come after? Any
thoughts? The teacher has said something
that everyone knows. So, why does this
announcement make a difference? Using
the language, maybe using the language
we've said before, how could saying
something, announcing something that
everyone already knows make a
difference? Yeah?
If player one
student one, student two both saw that
at least one hat was red. Right? And
both know that they don't share student
three's answer.
So, um maybe I didn't follow. Say Say
Student three can know based on what
student one said.
So, student three is learning from based
on what student one and student two are
saying. But let's be clear, if this if
the teacher had not made this
announcement and the teacher kept
saying, do you know your hat color?
Everyone would say no and we would just
go around
forever actually. So, the answers to the
questions are fundamentally changed by
this announcement that at least one hat
is red.
So, why does this announcement make a
difference? What what is changed by this
announcement? Using maybe a hint about
what we talked about over here. Yeah?
It's like everyone already knew that at
least one hat is red, but not everyone
knew that.
Yeah, in fact everyone knew that
everyone knew it, but it's not the case
that everyone knew that everyone knew
that everyone knew it. So, why did this
announcement make a difference? It took
something that was mutual knowledge, in
fact if we're careful it's second order
mutual knowledge, but it was not common
knowledge and it made that common
knowledge. So, announcements about
things that everyone know can change
things if that thing that everyone knows
is only mutual knowledge and not common
knowledge.
So, the crucial thing about this
announcement is it makes
an event
go from mutual knowledge
everyone knows it
to common knowledge.
And I think this really highlights
how fundamentally different these two
concepts are. So, let's try to work
through and see how we how we actually
get this. And then we'll
conclude.
So, first we have to model the state
space, right? So, each of the three
students has a hat and the hat can
either be white or red.
I find it easier to use binary here. So,
let's say we're going to say white is
going to correspond to zero
and red is going to correspond to one.
So, what is a state omega?
Well, a state omega is going to be
something like 010.
This would mean
player one's hat is white player two's
hat is red and player three's hat is
white. So, I'm going to rep- represent
the state by a by three binary digits,
each one indicating whether that
corresponding student's hat is red. So,
I'll just note here, this is student
two's hat color.
Now,
this means that we have eight states and
it's turns out to be quite useful to
represent the states as the corners of a
cube.
So, let me
think about different axes here.
So, we have the first axis
the second axis
and the third axis.
This will kind of test my drawing
abilities here.
Uh I think
I can do this.
So, we need
I draw that right?
Sorry, this keeps kind of jumps at you.
Um
Let me see how I did it here.
There we go.
Yeah, let me draw this a bit
differently.
I don't know if it makes more sense to
me or just or it might make more sense
to other people, too.
Uh
I think
should
Yeah.
I'm starting right here.
I should have done better in drawing
class here.
Let's see. Uh
it makes sense on my paper, but then I
can't draw it here.
Okay. I think it should be
Yeah.
There we go.
That looks better. Okay.
So, we have
so, this is state 111.
This is state 000.
And as we move on this axis, we increase
component one by one. As we move along
this axis
we increase component two by one and as
we move along this axis, we increase
component three by one.
So,
my picture
Okay, I think there we go. Okay.
So, now let's think about the
information partitions.
So, what is player one's information
partition?
Well, player one's partition has four
cells. The player one observes the
colors of the other two students' hats,
but they don't observe their own hat.
So, we can think of each cell of the
partition as being a horizontal line.
And make it a bit messy when I keep
drawing everyone else's, player two's is
going to be
like this.
And then player three's partition
is going to be like this.
It's going to be all.
So, let's understand what that means.
In this cell of the partition, player
one sees that the other two players'
hats are white, but player one doesn't
know her own hat color. She knows her
her hat can either be white or red.
Let's go up to this cell.
Well, this point here is 001.
So, here player one sees that player
two's hat is white and player three's
hat is red,
but she doesn't know her own hat color,
and that's why these two
um
are are going to be like this.
Okay. So, this is Any questions about
this this information structure?
Um
Great. So, now let me try to formalize
my claim.
My claim here was that the event that at
least one hat is red is mutual
knowledge, but not common knowledge. So,
let's try to try to check that.
Um so, let's write this down. This event
E Maybe I'll write E greater than equal
to one.
This is the event that at least one
student's hat is red.
I'll write this as a triple.
So, the event that at least one
student's hat is red is the event that
omega one plus omega two plus omega
three is greater than equal to one.
In fact, if we draw it on the graph,
this is the event that's everything
except this point. So, it's the event
containing all seven points of the cube,
which I've quite messily drawn, but
hopefully it looks you can see it now,
except this point here.
So, now we're going to have to do a bit
of calculation, so let's
let's come over here.
So, now let's ask
what is K1
of E greater than one?
So, this is in which states
does player one know
that at least one player's hat is red?
I want to be clear here. Over here, I
was talking about the true state being
red red red,
but for these statements about
knowledge,
they don't depend on what the true state
is. These are just statements about in
which state something is known. They
don't depend on the real estate.
So, what is this going to be?
Omega in omega such that
what?
Yeah. Omega two plus omega three is
greater than equal to
Exactly. So, I only know at least
someone's hat is red if I see a red hat.
And I'm player one, I see hats two and
three. I look at them. If either of
those is red, then I know at least one
person's hat is red. So, this is the
event that W2 plus W3
is greater than equal to one.
And, you know, symmetrically
for player two, it's the same thing, but
it's W1 plus W3 is greater than equal to
one.
Because if I'm player two, I can only
observe the hats of player one and
player three.
And then finally, K3
So, now that we've done
these calculations,
we can say, "Well, what is K of E?"
Which you remember is the intersection
K1 of E
intersect K2 of E.
Well,
W2 plus W3
has to be at least one.
W1 plus W3 has to be at least one.
And W1 plus W2 has to be at least one.
Um it turns out this is exactly going to
be the event that at least two hats are
red.
Let's see how we can see this.
I think it's kind of easier maybe to
reason in words.
If only one person's hat is red, then
the person with a red hat sees two white
hats.
So, they're not certain that at least
one person's hat is red.
But if at least two hats are red, then
everyone must see at least one red hat,
and therefore know that at least one hat
is red.
So, formally, if we maintain this
notation here, this is E
greater than equal to two.
So, let's see if we can kind of continue
this pattern.
So, we've said that K of E
greater than equal to one
is E greater than equal to two.
The event that everyone knows at least
one hat is red
is exactly the event that at least two
hats are red. You need one more red hat
for people to know that at least one hat
is red.
And now
let's ask, "What is K squared
of E greater than equal to one?"
This is the event that everyone knows
that everyone knows that at least one
hat is red.
Well, from what we said over here,
this is K of E
greater than equal to two.
This means everyone knows
that at least two hats are red.
And then I guess it's Can we just reason
through
in which states does everyone know that
at least two of the three hats are red?
Uh yeah.
All three hats are red.
So, this is going to be
E3.
Because if
if anyone's hat was white,
then
a person seeing that white hat would
only be seeing one red hat, and they
wouldn't be certain that there are at
least two red hats.
Okay.
So, now
final step, what is K3
of E greater than equal to one?
This is K
of E3.
So,
in which states
does everyone know that there are three
red hats?
Yeah.
Uh
Let's think. So, do we do we know if
Let's say everyone has three red hats.
Do we all know that everyone has three
red hats?
No. So, actually this is the empty set.
Cuz even if everyone has three red hats,
we don't all know that because I only
know the hats of the other two people.
So, here we can formalize our claim.
In state
omega equals 111,
well, the event at least one person's
hat is red
is mutual knowledge.
It's second order mutual knowledge,
but it's not third order mutual
knowledge.
So, in this state,
the event E1
is maybe I'll say second, but not third
order mutual knowledge.
And I think the reason this puzzle is so
confusing to people is that we have
pretty good intuition about mutual
knowledge. We have pretty weak intuition
about second order mutual knowledge, and
once you get to third or fourth order
mutual knowledge, it's really hard for
us to reason through it. It feels like a
lot like common knowledge. So, in this
game, because this event is second order
mutual knowledge, it sort of feels a lot
like common knowledge, but in fact, it's
not actually third order mutual
knowledge, and therefore certainly is
not common knowledge.
And that's why this announcement can
make such a big difference. Let me pause
to see if there's any questions uh
on this, and then we'll see if we can
actually
resolve the riddle.
Questions? Yeah.
Like, I guess every word is continued.
Does that mean like the other students
Uh you're saying if we if we ask more
questions here?
If we ask the fourth question?
Yeah, it turns out we actually cycle.
Then it gets it gets even more
confusing, and it's going to depend on
what the state is. Um but you can
actually have situations where it would
it would cycle.
Um where
uh
you sort of you might think, "Oh, we're
just learning more and more
information." But yeah, you can actually
have this kind of weird cycling pattern
where
uh the answers the subsequent answers
now change, and and we keep going on
forever. Um yeah.
Any other questions?
Yes.
Uh this is my answers change. Does that
mean maybe a student
sees three red hats and knows their hat
color? Or a student thinks
You're right. So, if I
if I know my hat color, I can never
subsequently
forget my hat color. That's true. So,
what am I thinking in this example? Let
me I should double-check this. Uh
Yes, so more information can never cause
you to not know something that you
previously knew. Um but there is a
similar riddle where these answers can
cycle. So, they must be asking about do
you know something about
must be something about something other
people knowing something about you. Let
me follow up with that. Yeah, let me let
me double-check that. You're right. Uh
that more information adding information
can never cause you to uh
Yes, to to forget something you once
knew.
Okay. So, now let's see if we can
actually uh resolve the the puzzle and
kind of see see what's happening here.
So
I think it's best to
go to the picture here and go through
the questions.
Uh
So, here we are.
The teacher, I guess,
first makes an announcement.
I'll go here.
So, this these stages.
The teacher makes an announcement
basically
they say the event is e greater than
equal to one. The teacher says
at least one person's hat is red.
But crucially, this announcement makes
this event common knowledge.
And what it means is now everyone knows
that everyone knows that everyone knows
that we're not in this state.
Let me put an X over this state.
So
now we're going to go to player one.
And we're going to ask player one
do you know your hat color?
That is, do you know that your hat is
white or do you know that your hat is
red or you're not sure?
And let's go through each of player
one's information sets.
So
if the state of the world is in this
information set, does player one know
their hat color?
No, because player one thinks either
they're in this state or they're in this
state and they know know their hat
color.
If they're in this information set,
player one also doesn't know their hat
color.
And same with this information set.
Uh but
if player one is in this information set
well, now because we've announced that
the state is not 000, basically what's
happened is this information set has
split into two.
The partition has changed. And in fact,
if we're really formal about it, that's
true for
for this one
and also for this one.
It gets messy to keep writing this, but
the announcement that the state is not
000 splits up any of the information
sets any of the cells that includes this
state 000. So, it splits up this one,
this one, and this one.
So, now
when we ask player one do you know your
hat color? And player one says no.
What is that what do all the other
players now learn about the state? What
is the one state that they can rule out?
Yeah.
This one, right? Because if the state
were here
player one would know for certain that
uh his hat was red.
So, now the players we break this up.
And I want to be really clear here what
these questions are doing is they're
changing the information partitions that
the players have.
Uh
again, this one is going to split up
and this one is going to split up.
Because now all the players learn that
we're not here.
Now, let's go to player two.
So, next player two is asked, do you
know your hat color?
Well, let's look.
If the state
is in this information set or this cell
for player two, then player two doesn't
know their hat color.
If it's in this cell then player two
also doesn't know their hat color.
But if it's in either of these four
points, the player does know their hat
color because now these four points are
in distinct singleton information sets
for player two. Because previously these
two were in the same information set in
the same cell, but that was split by the
first announcement.
And then these two were in the same
cell, but that was split by player one's
uh answer.
So, when player two says no
I don't know my hat color
that tells us that the state is not here
or here.
So, now everyone knows
that the state must be up in this uh
higher horizontal plane.
Player
one
knows we're either
in this information set or this
information set and they actually know
which one they're in.
Player two sees this, but player one now
player three actually per now perfectly
knows the state. Why? Because if the
state is here, then player three knows
it. If the state is here, player three
knows it. If the state is here, player
three knows it. And if the state is
here, player three knows it. So, now
player three, when the state is actually
111, is able to conclude uh that the
state must be here and therefore the
answer is yes.
This can be a little confusing. So,
yeah. Can you please repeat what you
said about after player two answered,
how that allows player one to know the
state?
Yes.
So, before player two
answers, I think maybe maybe another way
of looking at it. Let's focus on player
three.
Uh so, maybe another way of looking at
it without breaking information sets is
player three's information set is this
one.
Because the state is 111
we're saying suppose the realized state
is that everyone's hat is red.
So, that means that player three knows
either
my hat is red and the other two players'
hats are red
or my hat is white and the other two
players' hats are red.
Put this up here.
These are the only two possibilities
that player three entertains because
they can observe the other two players'
hats.
Now
player one player three now says, "Well,
wait a second.
Suppose the state were this.
If the state were 110
and that means that my hat is white, but
the other two player hat players' hats
are red then let me put myself in the
shoes of player two.
So, if this were the state then player
two's information set
would be this.
But player two
has learned from player one's answer
that this can't be the state.
So, if this were the state, then player
two would know for certain that this
were the state and therefore player two
would have said yes to this question.
So, it must be the case because player
two says no, that we can't be in this
state and therefore we must be in this
state and knowing that we're in this
state, I know that my hat is red.
Great. So, I think I want to end a bit
early since it's the last class, but uh
I'll stop there. Thanks.